>> SO,
AN
ATE PAEM
WITH 60 PEOPLE
HOSPITAL.
>>> MY NEXPOORIE TAYLOR
GREENE TO TRY TO ENCOURA
JOINING US NOW IS DR.
COWAN, HE LOST E BL PRIMARY TTAR
.
YOL RAYOU FOBEING WITH US.
SPEAKING PEOPLE, I
THINK THERE WALEVACCINATION CLI.
HOW PEOPLE DIDN AR
>> GOOD MORNING.
THAN ME.
WE DIDN'T GET ANYBODY TO TAK
E DID DO WAS PUT A
POSITIVEN  GETTING
E COMMUNITY HAT VACCINAT
THTHEIR RELATIVE, ACCINE W
PEOPHOED THEM IN OTHER
TATE ONT OF FOLKS RALLY.
ANPII
HOPE THEO GIVE
>> YOU DELIVERHOYO?S RIGHES THAI
GENERAL?
HOWA YOU T RECEIVED, I SHOULD
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE VACCINE?
>> -- GOT UP AND GAVE RY
PRAGE.
THE BOOTH, THAEVERYBODY FOR BEIT
LOOK'VE BEEN ON CO
SHIFT FOR A YEAR AND A HALF.
PEOPLE WHO JUST NEED TO VE G
THE LIFEOARTAT
ERE,E DESTROYING  O BTSTH DD TO
VE
WEAVEN BOATS
>>AGDOPEOPLE ARENATIF PEOPLEGET.
IT GOOD THATOULI
TH
I DON'T KNOW IT WAS AT THIS
RALLY, BUT MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE SAYS GSUBLICLY
ABOUT THE VACCINE H JUST
AREN'T TRUE AND SHE'S GOA
OF PTTENTION.
>> SHE DUNATELY.
SHE SAYS A LOT OTH
ARE  WOULDRAGE
YOU TO BRING HERN ANLENGE HER O.
I'M DOING THE BEAN TO PROMOTE A
VACCINATION.
ALLY AS VACCINE. DEVELOPED U
LOES
BIDEN.
WE HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
LICAHEY  PLEASE JU
THEY'RE GOING TO TELU TO
VAC>> YOU KVACCINE HAS NO